in a constant struggle between his
American and Taiwanese backgrounds as a
child award-winning food author Frankie
gaw wanted nothing more than to fit in
with his classmates in the midwest but
as he figured out what it means to be
Asian-American he was caught between
homemade dumplings and Costco hot dogs
now in his debut cookbook first
generation God writes of family memories
in self-discovery while sharing recipes
rooted in Taiwan as well as those
influenced by the American culinary
dream we visited him in his home state
of Ohio
I usually do like size of a ping pong
ball
oh yeah that's like our family yeah he
and his mother continue the tradition
today Generations huddled around the
kitchen island what kind of dumpling
flavors did Grandma this one now the
food author is Sherry his family's
recipes for home style cooking along
with dishes influenced by his Midwestern
Roots what was it like growing up in
Ohio I basically grew up in my house as
a Taiwanese family but then outside is
very much my American upbringing even
when Gaul left eventually landing on the
west coast a sense of Home beckoned
the now 31 year old was at the top of
the tech industry in his 20s helping
design Facebook live before starting a
food blog its title little fat boy
inspired by loving family nickname I
knew I wanted to celebrate the food from
my family and do it in a way that almost
like I would approach it from like a
product perspective so to me the product
was this food that I grew up with that I
hadn't really seen that much in food
media
what began as a way to document his
family's recipes
[Music]
quickly found a following combining his
design and photography skills gauze
Showcase of Taiwanese home cooking once
a verse blog of the Year award in 2019.
so this is the dough this is the dose
it's not just ingredients that are
featured Once you pull it it'll divide
it so then you'll be able to pull it
apart but also technique that's great
see
this is too long no so you can you can
you can pull it apart here but the food
God now celebrates was once the source
of embarrassment
you used to be ashamed of these dishes
so much so that you would never bring
them to school yeah I wanted to very
much fit in within my American
upbringing and because I was one of the
only Asians like within school I already
stood out God describes emulating
classmates as a way of social survival
including when his dad sent him on a
camping trip was Taiwanese scallion
pancakes
but then as soon as you got on that trip
you threw it away yeah he made me a
batch of Pancakes that he was like you
can cook these at the campfire it would
be super cool and I just like tossed
them in the trash because I was like
there's no way I'm gonna cook these very
foreign scallion pancakes in front of
all my friends who aren't Asian it's
funny now because like I would want to
make that dish over and over for all my
friends today because it's just so
delicious instead his lunches were a
kaleidoscope of American junk food I'll
get gushers and fruit roll-ups and
Cinnamon Toast Crunch like these are all
in I went all in on like the Midwest
like uh Greatest Hits and that was my
identity and and I still love those
Foods just as much as I loved my
Taiwanese Foods they were I think at
that time just very much in their own
like different worlds and I never let
them kind of cross
generation features traditional
Taiwanese dishes like Ramen noodles
drizzled in a mix of ginger and garlic
peanut sauce alongside creative
innovations that reflect his childhood
gau's Chinese sausage corn dogs pay
homage to the Costco ones he'd microwave
after school this is a very distinct
flavor it has this interesting mix of
feeling like you're at a carnival in
Ohio and eating a dim sum so there's
also chili crisp and honey roasted
chicken yeah go for it and butternut
squash and pork dumplings what are you
making Poco alongside Pearl meatballs
like his grandmother made eating um rice
meatballs the rice is sticky sweet
glutinous rice The Filling is a pork and
cabbage very traditional filling with
Gingers and scallion
and this is delicious gauze Cincinnati
chili with hand pulled noodles are
topped with Parmesan cheese their
flavors cumin cinnamon and even
unsweetened chocolate the inspiration
one of Ohio's best known dishes Skyline
Chili this is one of Cincinnati's most
famous restaurants yeah this is a
Cincinnati staple they're known for
their chili our order the four-way thank
you very much ah look at that oh my gosh
there's so much cheese a lot of cheese
spaghetti topped with chili onions and
yes plenty of cheese this like became
our family's tradition I feel like one
of our first like truly American
traditions that we kind of adopted into
our own family you came to Skyline Chili
a lot with your dad yeah this is one of
his favorite places to go he always got
the chili spaghetti so I think that
would be called a two-way technically
without the cheese without the cheese he
was very lactic he couldn't eat the
cheese
God's cookbook is dedicated in part to
his father Ben who passed away from
cancer in 2014. his death pushed God to
question who he is and in the book he
calls himself his father's son he wrote
a letter to your dad in this book yeah
it's essentially my coming out letter to
him because I never got to come out to
him before he passed his passing was
almost the Catalyst for me to come out
because it was the jump start to a lot
of me figuring out my identity and so
this is kind of me just reflecting back
on my dad and the foods that he would
cook for me and me wanting to explain to
him where I'm at now in my life today if
I could talk to him still a
re-examination of food and family
God to embrace his identity and food he
writes has been at the heart of
discovering both deep shame and
overflowing Pride a lot of my asian-ness
was suppressed it's only been within the
last few years what I've really thought
through these recipes and these stories
and and taken the time to celebrate them
the
Crunch cereal got loved as a child
Cheers Cheers yeah
his Nostalgia focusing on the sweet in
the Bittersweet if there's anything that
you could tell
eight-year-old Frankie what would you
say oh
I would say don't Chuck this guy in
pancakes they're gonna be your career
one day
and I would just say hey in the end
no one's going to care as much as you
care so you should just be yourself and
because in the end it's not even going
to matter it's only how it matters to
you and where you want to go so I think
that's what I would say to myself
words to live by and we did bring that
Mochi that Frankie was talking about
here we do we actually have two sweet
treats made by our producer Emily de
Alessandro and yourself thanks Emily and
thank you she made the Mochi I also made
these Rice Krispie treats they are
oolong milk tea and almond Rice Krispie
treats and so you finally grind the
Oolong tea so that it really infuses all
of this it is my first time baking for
y'all so you got to tell me what you
think it's good I like it I had a little
bit thank you for doing that by the way
I know that's never baked for us and I
never will I
do like by the way I do like the cheers
the the dessert shears yes oh yeah all
right here cheers
there we go cheers